King viserys missed something major in
the eighth episode of House of the
Dragon did you from New Gods to new
aegons to a meaningful dance here's
everything you might have missed
while Damon rhaenyra and their brood
have been away at Dragonstone Alison has
been busy redecorating the red keep upon
their arrival Damon immediately notices
a huge and prominently displayed
seven-pointed star Allison's erected new
statues of the seven the Green's Garb is
ornamented with impossible to miss
seven-pointed stars and prayer has
become routine before dinner later when
there's a dead body to be tended to the
silent sisters a religious order within
the faith of the seven perform their
rights and it suggested that rhaenice
should follow their Customs harder to
miss is the fact that Allison is erasing
as much Targaryen ephemera from the red
keep as possible
Alison has found religion as a way to
redeem herself the hightower's lured
over Old Town which is also where the
faith of the seven is headquartered both
the hightowers and the faith have an
uneasy relationship with the targaryens
and view themselves as morally superior
to the dragon riding valyrians but
Alison's hypocrisy is laid bare when her
son aegon rapes a servant girl she has
the maesters Brew their abortifacient
tea for the girl the same one that she
judged rhaenyra so harshly for being
prescribed after her night with Damon
and Sir Kristen for plenty of practical
reasons most of the children in House of
the Dragon are born in between time
jumps by episode 8 which takes place at
least six years after episode seven
Damon and rhaenyra have had two sons and
she's pregnant with a third child when
they sail for King's Landing we can
gather that she probably hasn't seen her
father since the wedding as she says she
wants to introduce the king to his new
grandchildren first he gets to meet
toddler aegon then he makes the
acquaintance of the baby boy viserys
whom the old man says has the name of a
king rhaenyra and Damon certainly knew
what they were doing when they
christened their eldest son aegon and
their younger son viserys sure they both
share a fondness for Targaryen history
and culture and they both earnestly love
their father and brother but it doesn't
hurt that the king is flattered and
might continue to favor these boys and
their side of the family for succession
Rainier's choice of name is also meant
to be a not so subtle slight to Alison
not only is she the named Heir she's got
an aegon of her own now and one of pure
Targaryen Heritage and the book Ellison
takes great offense that this new aegon
the younger as he's referred to in Fire
and Blood at this point rhaenyra and
jacaris know their claims to the throne
are solid so long as the king lives but
their public support grows ever shakier
Jace is also aware of his uncle aegon's
reputation however despite the fact that
aegon II is a white-haired boy with the
last name Targaryen and no rumors
swirling around about his parentage he's
also a Laos without ambition and a
sexual predator to boot the more
traditional people of King's Landing and
the realm at large may think they want
aegon II in theory but once they see him
in action they might change their minds
after aegon makes distasteful jokes in
bayla's presence to whom Jace is now
betrothed and after Helena's toast to
her husband is a little too accurate for
everyone's Comfort level Jace stands up
and like a gentleman asks Elena to dance
in both the book and the show aegon
takes this as an insult as he should
Jace is suggesting by his simple good
behavior that he's not only the rightful
Heir but the Better Man by extending the
offer of a dance to awkward Helena he's
not only showing his aunt kindness but
effectively playing politics there's
also the added symbolism of the dance
itself between one member of the greens
and one of the blacks the conflict on
the horizon will be known as the dance
of the dragons and Helena and Jace who
are both Dragon Riders will be involved
earlier in episode 8 visera sits on his
throne for the last time with great
difficulty then admits to some confusion
he doesn't understand why claims to
driftmark are being entertained when the
matter has already been decided this is
some shrewd rhetoric on the king's part
in this situation viserys realizes that
vamund and the greens are trying to cut
his cousin rhaenice and daughter
rhaenyra out of House Targaryen and
house valarian's lines of succession but
after a quick extrajudicial beheading
and Last Supper that devolves into the
violence the very moment the king leaves
the room Allison tucks her husband into
bed where he forces out a less Lucid
final thought before presumably passing
away all by his Lonesome referring to
aegon's dream he says he wanted to know
if I believe it to be true the queen has
no idea what he's talking about
to remember
aegon
our son
visceros continues explaining as though
Allison understands concluding with it
is you you are the one you must do this
those are the king's final words Allison
takes this to mean she must ensure that
their son aegon II ascends the iron
throne but based on context clues it's
obvious that viserys who is blind on the
side where Allison sits and mere seconds
from Death thinks he's talking to his
daughter Rainier there's precedent for
this in the previous episode in which
viserys mistakes Alison for his late
wife Emma it's foreshadowed earlier in
the episode too
and
there's renira father
this is a major change from the book
that will reverberate throughout the
rest of the series
[Music]